[Music]
this morning we're hearing from the
stars of the first ghostbusters just
days before the release of the new film
in the popular movie franchise bill
murray dan aykroyd ernie hudson are all
returning in the highly anticipated
ghostbusters afterlife which hits
theaters on friday paul rudd and mckenna
grace also star in the new film we got a
chance to talk all things ghostbusters
with all five of them we met at the
fdny's latter eight firehouse in
manhattan a place that holds a special
meaning for the actors and the fans
you're the best we're the beautiful
we're the only
ghostbusters
it's a return many thought they'd never
see ghostbusters
[Music]
and to return to the original firehouse
in downtown manhattan together for the
first time in over 30 years what was it
like walking in here i flashed on the
scene where uh i bring the ecto home for
the first time you can't park that here
we shot that kind of in the entrance
here are you troubled by strange noises
in the night the franchise was a
cultural phenomenon all right
this chick is toast
that helped rocket bill murray dan
aykroyd harold ramis and ernie hudson by
your stick
to a rare level of global celebrity
paul i remember sitting down with you
seemed like a year or two ago asking
what do you have coming up next
you said i can't tell you much about it
but i am involved in one of the most
iconic franchises were you thinking to
yourself there's going to be added
stress and pressure to
fulfill the expectations there wasn't
any hesitation it was really just
excitement
one because i'm you know a fan of the
franchise i
love these guys like everybody else yeah
i'm friends with jason excuse me there's
a fire
i hate this
i like to torture him what was your
original fandom of the 1984
classic ghostbusters the cast
i'm i think like everybody in this room
just
tripping out that i'm sitting in the
firehouse with them right now it's the
coolest thing ever you know
the movie's iconic they're iconic hey
where these stairs go
[Music]
they go up a lot of the success goes to
rick and and and sigourney and then
bill's performance as a comic leading
man and then just the solidity of
ernie's presidents and the cerebral
influence of harold that's what you
wanted to say paul that's what you
should have said
i wanted to leave that for dan
you better bring him inside
the latest sequel will be without hail
ramus who died in 2014. oh nice shooting
tex reymus woke the original scripts
with aykroyd and played ghostbuster egon
spangler in the first two films that
first meeting was like
he was i know how we're going to do this
i know how this is going to work
follow my lead here it's going to happen
in the way that we all uh wanted to so i
just basically sat down with him as the
lead writer and without him uh we
wouldn't have the the intelligent
wonderful uh writing that uh that came
out of it
rising from the grave human sacrifice
dogs and cats living together macesteria
the original's always been like a really
big part of my life even though i i've
met you guys and worked with y'all it's
just still really really weird to
like mr paul said like be in the
firehouse with the ecto with the
original ghostbusters
fifteen-year-old mckenna grace first saw
the original when she was only three
years old she plays the granddaughter of
egon spangler in the new sequel
ghostbusters afterlife did i hit it it's
very emotional for ghostbusters film uh
and i think that that's
really special for people to be able to
watch like in the theater i'm looking
around and i'm seeing like people crying
and it's really special to be able to
see that our film has that kind of an
impact on people i'm just excited for
people to be able to watch it and be
excited about all of the call backs and
throwbacks call backs the throwbacks the
easter eggs the easter eggs it's so cool
people would describe this franchise as
cross-generational
why do you think it resonates with so
many different eras of fans i've seen
old people with their grandkids and
they're all laughing not many movies uh
do that so and i think there's a part of
us that always wonders about the
supernatural who's in the closet when
they turn the light out and ghostbusters
dealt with it in a way that was brave
and funny and i think that's why people
respond to it
bill there was an interview you did with
oprah
back in the 80s
and it was you
dan ernie harold she asked were you even
a little surprised by the success of the
first one and you jumped in right away
and you said no
really no not at all not at all how did
you know when you are a man you know
you're not yet men you're still boy
but when you are a man you know it's big
we
have been shooting and
we had thanksgiving at ivan reitman's
house and he happened to show us just a
little piece of something that we shot
when we've caught the first ghost
and i went back to work that day and
said
guys we can all relax
this is going to be really really big
you had a feeling i knew right away this
stuff was so funny tearing up that hotel
ballroom i mean the first 45 minutes of
ghostbusters is about as funny as a
movie can be that's these guys writing
this stuff but yeah
everything was just hanging drove the
ship man you you put the throttles man
wow the greatest comedy leading man of
his generation is it a star
it is a star very good that's great
you are named the sexiest man alive paul
thinking back on this film was it hard
to shoot with just
normal humans
oh that's a great question almost unfair
really yeah you are the sexiest man
alive paul no i don't think it's true
i agree with paul i don't believe that
paul is a sexist man alive but i
couldn't be happier that paul has to
answer these kinds of questions
for the rest of his life all the firemen
are looking at you like jesus
i see a lot of sexy firemen in here yeah
i know i mean yeah they're the ones with
the
person in the calendars
right now rich collucci okay bring him
forward we'll have him stand next to
paul and see which one the camera picks
up
rich looks good
can we get a side by side rich is
handsome i give it to rich i think it's
mister right here not even close
come look at this who can pull off like
a winter jacket and shorts
rich can i don't know what the weather
is outside how he's dressed i tell you
it's cold outside but it's hot by rich
[Laughter]
oh that's fun
shout out to the latter right firehouse
in manhattan they opened up their doors
and they were absolutely awesome and
have it yeah and paul rudd he embraced
the whole sexiest man alive yeah it's
good to have fun with it i do totally
totally i think those firefighters were
excited to have that fivesome in that
room i mean what an amazing lineup to
have for an interview i love when
mckenna who's 15
uh referred to paul rudd as mr paul
probably never felt 50 until that moment
yeah exactly bill murray always just
cracks me up donate yeah just he just
shows up in just his delivery it was so
fun to see all of them together yeah at
some point dan aykroyd he got up and he
did a little dance for us too they were
on 10. the movie's going to be great
it's going to be huge huge just like the
first one